on va jouer tous ensemble puisque on va
chanter maintenant on va faire quelque
chose d'un petit peu particulier c'est
parti nadège vous chante hé bien oui
mais vous fait peur oui je sais c'est ce
que souvent disent les femmes comptaient
alors vous allez venir avec moi la neige
parce qu'on va accueillir tout de suite
notre julien combes et ses bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rama iv plaisir dis moi tu passes au
sauna mervin tu n'as alors julien alesi
mettez-vous lamont juju juge va se
mettre là a lieu juste avant niveau des
jambes
vous avez quelques poils ouais vous avez
quand même quelques poils non vous
inquiétez pas monsieur du jus vous allez
nous chanter le lac du connemara de
michel charasse et bien vous allez
devoir chanter et de l'est il ya nadège
qui est ici qui a été esthéticienne
voilà bonsoir nadège voilà alors nadège
vous allez voir mais je ne sais pas la
soumettre à ce niveau là et vous allez
devoir donc voilà vous savez faire ou
pas non je suis maladroit tu voulais je
le passe merci nadège a laissé ses
sujets même si julien savoye là et on va
en mettre une petite dernière
voilà c'est bien moi je coche des piles
j'ai pu bien que julia donc vous
continuer à chanter les lacs du
connemara ensuite on aura nos amis en
les frérots de la vega qui font un petit
week-end son attention là et bien cela
la salle est alors voyez ça il faut bien
mettre ça comme ça ah oui c'est bon je
pense que ce soir je vais faire un petit
tour du côté du goût de me situer ça va
vous faire du bien
là bas
[Musique]
le prix du silence
ce mot
[Musique]
avis et u2
i
ça c'est drôle
en ce
vous allez commencer à chanter et à un
moment je sais pas pourquoi je sais pas
pourquoi va vous mettre un petit peu de
glace derrière le dos pour vous
rafraîchir d'accord ok on est reparti
vous sentez tranquille au maïs ou et
darling ces parties au liban
[Musique]
capa
[Applaudissements]
ah bah ça va
on est au fond des landes de claire
autour du billet là
c est pour les vivants enfin
il y a
[Musique]
c'est le
du débat
[Applaudissements]
il va être vos bras d'accord donc il va
essayer de vous faire manger ce plat de
spaghettis
pendant que vous sont tous d'accord
est-ce qu'on peut les installer à
l'essai s'il vous plaît merci les bras
le long du corps normal à la neige dans
le lointain
et attention on doit voir oui mais
dément attention c'est parti et vous
devez de fukushima touchée et vous
devrez toujours continué à chanter
l'accord nadège attention christophe
carrière vous lui donnez à manger des
pâtes
alors on va chanter je crois que c'est
serge gainsbourg est couleur café vous
qui avez choisi la couleur café ce que
vous saviez que vous allez chanter allez
ça y est c'est parti
oliva
[Musique]
là
ça
quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont entendu la nouvelle